how uncomfortable was it by the way for  you growing up having a hot mom like did  your friend say [ __ ] so I was showing  somebody a picture  um  a picture of you and a picture of mom  she was like why are your parents both  hot and I was like imagine that growing  up and going to school every time your  mom came into school your dude friends  like I want to [ __ ] your mom and then  every time your dad came into school all  the girls were like hey I want to [ __ ]  your dad and I was like hey could you  guys not want to [ __ ] my parents could  you just chill out on that for a little  bit like  you were like who wants to [ __ ] me like  yeah I'm The Best of Both Worlds what's  the [ __ ] deal  why am I still getting [ __ ] stuffed  in trash what the [ __ ]